he was known as the intellectual Pope
the son of a policeman a child who lived
through Nazi rule in 2005 Cardinal
Joseph ratzinger became Benedict XVI the
first German to be elected Pope in a
thousand years
an uncompromising theological
conservative Cardinals chose him as a
safe Pair of Hands
Benedict Was a shy person he loved books
he loved his desk writing reflecting
bringing in beautiful German and then
also in other languages his thought but
a lonely person
he was even telling people my true
friends are the books
nickname God's rottweiler for his
uncompromising conservative views is a
cardinal at times his eight-year papacy
was marked by missteps the
rehabilitation of a holocaust denier
angering Jews a clumsy speech
antagonizing Muslims
but many respected his deep faith
his strength was clearly how to express
the Christian faith in a way
understandable to Modern human beings
that's
his message that's what he leaves us
among Catholics Benedict Was widely
popular in 2010 he made the first ever
papal State visit to the UK welcomed by
a crowd of adoring pilgrims
before meeting Queen Elizabeth
politicians and giving dozens of sermons
but his visit was controversial for
critics who claimed he was not doing
enough to tackle sex abuse in the church
a topic which would haunt him into his
retirement
the number one challenge for Pope
Benedict Was the abuse crisis which was
just gaining it in in speed and
spreading all over the world during his
pontificate and he did take several
steps to begin to respond to that but
his critics say that he he didn't do
enough in the time that he was the pope
in 2013 tired by a Vatican League
Scandal and dogged by ill health
benedict made history again
this time becoming the first pope in 600
years to resign
in his final address to the faithful
he acknowledged the weight of the office
and the church's problems
it was a journey with joy and light but
there have also been difficult moments
than in an extraordinary chapter for the
Catholic church he said goodbye to the
Cardinals before retiring to a monastery
in Vatican City
that was a remarkable step he made and
there hadn't been a pop since the Middle
Ages though who stepped down so he as a
fairly conservative person was also
opening a door
to a world of today where people need
not to stay in office until they die
after retirement Benedict chose to keep
wearing white give interviews and not
revert his old name decisions critics
claimed threatened the unity in the
church
but the two popes personal relationship
was strong France is referring to his
predecessor as a grandfather figure and
asking people to pray for his friend as
his health deteriorated
he's very sick he told worshipers in
December asking the Lord to comfort him
to the very end
today Benedict is remembered again as
millions of Catholics around the world
pray for the man who led their church
for almost a decade
Sky News